hey dude taking I really appreciate this
three is your okay you know what
remember when we were at the W Hotel and
we shot that [ __ ] Gotham comedy live
whatever the yeah yeah and we and we we
were singing these kinds of songs yeah
in the lobby of the W Hotel and yeah
laughing crying laughing crying dude and
that weekend was a great weekend because
I got to host a comedy show where you
were on it it's so funny because now you
would never do that show well I mean
that's a show for like that was like one
of my first things right you know and
you killed it so hard it was fun it was
fun it was fun
I wore a [ __ ] shirt with the same
pattern a shirt with a pattern on it and
it had the same pattern tie and then we
were gonna watch a movie that week and
we're going to move in you just didn't
watch the movie with me
oh yeah well you you could probably do
weird [ __ ] on the road dude what do you
think like you probably like I heard
that you don't hang out with your
[ __ ] openers right no what the [ __ ]
sleeps all day I sleep all day but you
okay you don't hang with them at night
though no yeah that's [ __ ] weird why
why bring them then I'll tell you why
I'll tell you why you break them you
always do I bring them scream dude I
know because you ream scream scream all
the [ __ ] time no matter where you are
you scream because I'm right here this
room is [ __ ] smallish [ __ ] all right
I can hear you as well I'll tell you why
why because um why you have a vacuum
it's our state oh wow yeah there's a
they have a [ __ ] vacuum check cameras
I'm sorry um some say my pot some
podcasts are doing as well as some other
ones you know what much you very well
enough money to have a regular chat with
it's 17 ways one of the sun's gonna be
hearing in the middle of plugins like oh
we just had another one and then the
babies is gonna be here yeah I forgot
even what I was gonna say to you what
was I saying
oh why why I don't have my openers is
because just I don't number one it's not
it's not a French you bring Michael
emoji yeah yeah it's a friendship yeah I
don't bring openers as a friendship okay
my employees okay right yeah so whenever
they don't really you don't mix it up I
don't make no when I'm in a green room
right if I want to say to my employee
hey get me a diet coke yeah and they go
get me a diet coke right right as a
friend you can't do that oh I do it I
know you do it okay I know you do it
okay but like um I do it so that it's
more of like there are you know on the
payroll yeah and I don't really like
hanging out with you if you were on the
road with me yeah now I would have to
make I'd be like come on Bobby where the
[ __ ] are you
let's go come on let's hang out yeah but
where do you were you what do you do all
weekend we go to a Starbucks we hang the
[ __ ] out we do what we're doing right
now we laughs dude I know you're just
gonna hang around in some [ __ ] like
baggy shorts in his [ __ ] in his in
his hotel room and it's gonna you know
like I don't know why ostian I wanna be
like I wanted this to be so casual you
know Louis casual casual I know I know
but the thing is you're you're
infuriating eye-openers we go rock
climbing yeah Wow
so now you make her do it yeah do you
like it okay I love sandy I love all the
guys yeah you bring good guy yeah do you
Bobby don't do press on Friday mornings
deal no right so that's that's what I'm
saying isn't that you're at a point in
your career where you when you fly in
you know the shows are sold out right
most of the Papa show believe it or not
Papa show aim really yeah so what popeye
has to do is get up at 6:00 in the
morning on a Friday morning and do good
morning morning news Florida ABC News
this yeah you know Jack and Mike's radio
show in Atlanta or whatever and I have
to do five or six things that's the word
I know I come back to my hotel room it's
noon yeah and I haven't slept because I
flew in that night right
and I had to sleep all day yeah right so
I can't hang out
[Music]